now speaking of
different cultural perspectives on sex
it's a mild way to put child brides i
guess
the toy company lego
has a new set of toys out for kids it's
the queer eye toy queer eye the fab five
loft it's from queer eye for the
straight guy you remember that show and
it's all these gay guys who are interior
designers and a very popular show
so some people are very upset by this
they say we shouldn't have
a show called the queer eye they
shouldn't have little toys for kids and
i don't know i i
my problem is not with lego okay my
problem is not with the fact that this
this show that focuses on an aspect of
the sexual revolution was made into a
toy for kids
i think that's inevitable
i think that if you have a culture that
is really focused on sex sex of all
kinds
that even sort of an unusual sexual
desire would then be the kind of hook
for this very popular tv show that's
been on for many many years at this
point inevitably you're going to get
toys about that that's going to permeate
the whole culture
and there's no there's no way to
separate that i mean this is one of the
failures of the you do you idea of
society the libertarian i mean these are
the things we were debating yesterday in
dc and you can check out that panel at
the intercollegiate studies institute
is it just doesn't work because we
actually do live together in a polity in
a society and
my behavior actually will affect other
people the libs are kind of right about
this
and your behavior will affect me and the
prevailing standards and mores actually
will affect the kind of country that
we're going to have and it's going to
affect
the way that we individually develop as
well it's going to affect the way that
we raise our kids and so if you if you
have a problem with that then you need
to stand up and actually have the
cajones to say no we are not going to
tolerate certain shows on tv whether i
mean queer eye this seems kind of low on
the priority list of things that you've
got to get off tv but you're going to
say no we're not going to permit certain
things in the classroom no we're not
you've got to learn the magic word
no i'm so glad you like that clip stop
what you're doing please i beg you i'm
pleading stop what you're doing
take up your phone go to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your podcast type in the michael
knowles show hit subscribe
this helps us to avoid
some of the censorship that occasionally
takes place in certain platforms
appreciate it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you